Frau Merkel deutsche Einheit
Ostdeutschland Perspektive von
Zuwanderer Generationen 1 2 3 das ist
das Thema jetzt ist das hier ihr
allererstes TV-Interview seit abends
ausschalten warum haben Sie sich für
dieses Thema entschieden
ja das Thema als solches interessiert
mich und dann ist ja auch eine meiner
letzten reden die Rede zum Tag der
Deutschen Einheit gewesen in Halle am 3
Oktober 2021 und jetzt fand ich
eigentlich den Bezug recht interessant
und deshalb habe ich mich zu dem ersten
Interview wieder entschieden ja das war
ja sozusagen zu im letzten Jahr ihrer
Kanzlerschaft in Halle beim Staat sagt
dass sie diese Rede gehalten haben und
dabei haben sie etwas erwähnt dass ich
so ähnlich häufig gehört habe in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen auf meiner
drehreise sie haben davon gesprochen
dass ihre DDR-Vergangenheit als Ballast
bezeichnet wurde was haben sie was haben
sie dabei empfunden als sie das zum
ersten Mal gelesen haben weil es war ja
ein Artikel in dem das veröffentlicht
wurde
ja es war wie so eine kleine wir sind
kleiner Schlag in den Magengrube muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen
ich habe das war eine Darstellung meiner
Zeit als Parteivorsitzender als
CDU-Vorsitzende und ich habe irgendwie
erst gar nicht richtig glauben können
und dann habe ich noch mal gelesen aber
es war Ballast und da habe ich natürlich
irgendwo mich ja also entkernt gefühlt
weil alles was mich ausmacht natürlich
die Biografie das aufwachsene DDR war
und man kann ja nicht von einem Menschen
irgendetwas
abtrennen und insofern war ich einfach
baff da muss man erstmal drauf kommen
und das haben sie dann artikuliert in
dieser Rede und haben
hundertprozentig ein Nerv getroffen bei
vielen Millionen in Ostdeutschland und
ich habe mich gefragt
warum haben sie das erst so spät
formuliert diese Worte die sehr
eindeutig waren was hat Sie davon
abgehalten das vorher zu machen also
interessanterweise ist ja der Artikel
mir erst unter die Augen gekommen als
meine Parteivorsitzende Karriere schon
beendet war aber jetzt davon abgesehen
ich hätte so eine persönliche Bemerkung
in meiner Amtszeit wenn es jetzt nicht
zum Ende hingegangen wäre wahrscheinlich
nicht gemacht weil ich mich immer als
Kanzlerin aller deutschen verstanden
habe vielleicht auch manchmal nicht so
getraut habe aus der
DDR-Zeit frank und frei dauernd zu
sprechen weil das wieder auch so eine
Art Stigmatisierung geworden wäre jetzt
kommt sie wieder mit ihrem
Ostdeutschland oder so sondern ich habe
das dann viel mit mir selber ausgemacht
oder im Wahlkreis darüber gesprochen
aber eben nicht als Bundeskanzlerin ist
wie eine Monstranz vor mir her getragen
aber
ich war dann doch
auch erstaunt wie viele Leute dann das
auch als etwas verstanden haben was sie
auch angeht und insofern plädiere ich
doch dafür dass Gespräch darüber auch
immer wieder zu führen das habe ich
nämlich auch gedacht weil ich dachte sie
hätten ja eine Brücke schlagen können zu
denen die das so empfunden haben dass
nach der Wende gab es viele
Enttäuschungen eben auch durch das was
sie gerade beschrieben haben dass man
sozusagen abgewertet wurde die die
Biografie quasi ausgelöschte fand dann
nicht mehr statt dann hätten sie doch
viele Millionen früher mitnehmen können
oder naja es ist ja nicht so dass ich
nie darüber gesprochen habe also ich
habe immer auch darüber geredet dass es
ein Unterschied gibt zwischen dem Staat
DDR dessen Überwindung wäre natürlich
alle begeistert gefeiert haben und ein
persönlichen Leben das ja in jedem Land
mehr ist als nur die staatliche Struktur
Gott sei Dank und auch die DDR hat es
trotz aller Versuche Jugendliche immer
wieder zu beeinflussen natürlich nicht
geschafft die Familie zu ersetzen und
man hatte Freunde man hat gefeiert wir
sind mit den Eltern in Urlaub gefahren
das waren ja alles Erlebnisse und dann
gibt es noch die prägenden Erlebnisse
durch den Start ich meine die
Anwesenheit von Freiheit formt Menschen
aber die Abwesenheit von freiheitsform
sie ja auch und da erlernt man auch
wichtige Dinge darüber hatte ich schon
gesprochen aber ehrlich gesagt mir wäre
auch gar nicht im Kopf gekommen ich
hätte das ja selber nicht
niederschreiben können dass jemand
schreibt die Biografie in der DDR war
Ballast
sicherlich sie waren die Kanzlerin aller
Deutschen aber in meiner Wahrnehmung
haben sie im Osten zumindest in den
letzten Jahren sehr viele
Missmut abbekommen da sind waren die
Leute richtig richtig sauer womit
erklären Sie sich das naja es gab einen
Teil der Menschen die sehr wütend auf
mich waren das hat sich hat begonnen
während der Zeit als der Euro in
Schwierigkeiten kam aber dann als auch
sehr viele Flüchtlinge zu uns kamen da
hat sich die Lage polarisiert aber ich
habe auch immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen würde dass hier auch gerne
noch mal tun dass ich ja immer mein
Wahlkreis gewonnen habe also es ist ja
nicht so dass die Mehrzahl der Menschen
in den neuen Bundesländern mich
angeschrien hätte sondern es gab einen
Teil und eine sehr radikale und auch
laute und intolerante Gruppe aber sehr
sehr viele Menschen haben das natürlich
ganz anders gesehen und es ist auch
etwas bekümmerlich jetzt fast dass
sozusagen der lauteste den letzten
Eindruck hinterlässt und viele Menschen
die leise und auch sich dagegen wehren
gegen diese Intoleranz die kommen viel
weniger zu Wort und das ist auch nicht
in Ordnung
fällt auf auf meiner drehreise sind mir
in Ostdeutschland häufig Menschen
begegnet ganz normale Lehrer Ingenieure
und so weiter die Verständnis dafür
geäußert haben dass die Menschen im
Osten verstärkt AFD wählen verstehen sie
das
nein also ich möchte dafür kein
Verständnis äußern weil ich glaube ich
verstehe dass man über manches verärgert
ist dass man nicht alles gut findet
aber ich bin nicht bereit zu akzeptieren
dass man deshalb Ideen und Gedankengut
unterstützt was für mich
nichts mit dem was ich als Toleranz oder
was im Rahmen meiner Toleranz akzeptabel
ist und wenn man sich sozusagen auf
Kosten anderer Menschen auch anders
aussehender Menschen von Menschen mit
anderer Biografie profiliert dann ist
das nichts wofür ich Verständnis habe da
würde ich immer dagegen argumentieren
und würde sagen man kann in dieser
demokratischen Gesellschaft wirklich
auch anders seine Kritik und seinen
Ärger zum Ausdruck bringt eine Person
mit Migrationshintergrund und ich habe
die Erfahrung gemacht dass ich im Osten
häufiger mit Rassismus konfrontiert
werde
und ich frag mich woran das liegt
ja es ist bedauerlich und
auch wie gesagt erstmal nicht zu
akzeptieren aber es wenn Sie das
persönlich so berichten dass das bei
Ihnen so ist dann
muss man es vielleicht damit erklären
dass es nicht die Vielfalt an Biografien
öffentlich gab es wir hatten ja auch
viele vietnamesische
Vertragsarbeiter angolanische
Vertragsarbeiter aber die wurden ja
geradezu weggesperrt aus dem
öffentlichen Leben die durften nicht
reisen mit oder nur unter bestimmten
Bedingungen wohnten in abgeschotteten
Wohnheim und ähnlichem und es ist
vielleicht auch so dass die Menschen die
die
Veränderung erlebt haben also außer DDR
dann in die deutsche Einheit hingegangen
sind und das ja im Grunde ein großer
Menge begrüßt haben
die haben natürlich sehr viel Umbrüche
mitbekommen und ich weiß noch als der
aus meiner Zeit Anfang der 90er Jahre
als ich jugendministerin war das ist
fast so ein bisschen ein Wettbewerb auch
gab wenn ich mit türkischstämmigen
Jugendlichen gesprochen habe dann haben
sie gesagt jetzt sind wir eine Klasse
runtergerutscht die besten sind
natürlich die Westdeutschen Jugendlichen
dann kommt der Ostsee dran das habe ich
auch so ähm und dann kommen wir erst
also wir hatten auch richtig
existenzärzte und viele haben sie eben
auch vielleicht mehr eine Konkurrenz
gesehen in in Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund aber akzeptabel
ist es deshalb trotzdem nicht aber das
was sie gerade haben das habe ich auch
in Köln gehört wo wir bei einer
türkischen Familie gedreht haben
Ausgrenzung Arbeitsplätze
Ausbildungsplätze knapp und dann hatten
die wirklich Angst wenn sie mit gleichen
schulergebnissen kommen das dann doch
wieder der deutschstämmige aus dem Osten
eher genommen wird als derjenige der mit
dem Migrationshintergrund kommt
Ausgrenzung Abwertung vorurteilskultur
und Herkunft als Makel ist es vielleicht
etwas das ostdeutsche und Migranten
verbindet
ich glaube es verbindet Menschen immer
die eine Minderheiten Biografie haben
ich würde jetzt gar nicht
sozusagen
aufmachen sondern wenn man aus einer
ganz speziellen Herkunft vielleicht auch
mit besonderen Eltern im Westen kommt
kann einem das auch passieren dass man
ausgegrenzt wird es gibt eine gewisse
Tendenz die sozusagen den
durchschnittlichen Lebenslauf für das
gegebene zu halten und ich habe immer
dafür plädiert dass unsere Stärke ja
eigentlich die Vielfalt ist und wenn wir
das immer weiter eingrenzen was ist noch
normal
dann
ist man sehr schnell dabei dass man viel
zu viele Menschen ausgrenzt und es gibt
vielleicht eine gewisse Tendenz im
Augenblick alles zu vereinheitlichen und
damit auch zu verkürzen und deshalb
plädiere ich immer für Vielfalt ja man
muss halt differenzieren aber das ist
sehr anstrengend man muss ja dann seine
respektieren und das ist ja das Wesen
unserer Demokratie und auch Europas ich
habe zusammen mit unserer ersten
Ratspräsidentschaft 2007 mal eine Rede
im Europäischen Parlament gehalten und
da Karl schabek den tschechischen
Schriftsteller
zitiert der gesagt hat der Schöpfer
Europas hat es klein gemacht und dann
noch in winzige Teile geteilt damit sich
unsere Herzen an der Vielfalt erfreuen
und die Vielfalt ist ja eigentlich das
schöne dass die Menschen nicht gleich
geboren werden sondern unterschiedlich
geworden werden und das bedeutet
natürlich auch dass ich mich in die
Schuhe des anderen hineinversetzen muss
aus dem Blickwinkel gucken muss aber das
ist ja auch eine Bereicherung
ich komme zur letzten Frage Frau Merkel
sie haben mal gesagt
als sie halt Kanzlerin waren ich bin die
Bundeskanzlerin aller deutschen das
schließt alle die hier dauerhaft leben
mit ein jetzt bezogen auf die deutsche
Einheit Frau Merkel braucht Deutschland
eine neue Erzählung die zugewandelte die
eben dauerhaft hier leben miteinschließt
ja selbstverständlich es braucht diese
Erzählung es braucht es eigentlich schon
immer aber da wir ja jetzt auch in den
letzten Jahren sehr viele Menschen
haben die
dauerhaft in unserem Land leben und noch
nicht immer hier gelebt haben ist das
wieder eine neue Aufgabe dass wir sie
mit aufnehmen ja
Deutschland umfasst alle ich habe
darüber auch mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan sehr häufig
gesprochen wer ist verantwortlich zum
Beispiel für türkischstämmige Menschen
die hier zweite dritte Generation wohnen
und ich habe immer gesagt pass auf dass
deren Bundeskanzlerin bin ich
vielen Dank für das Gespräch danke dass
Sie sich Zeit genommen haben vielen Dank